so it uh it's two minutes after ten I'm
gonna go ahead and convene division
three uh we we do have uh a quorum we
have two substitutes on the on the
Republican side uh representative Leon
is here in here for
um uh representative verf representative
colfault is here for representative Hull
uh representative nordgren has said that
she's coming but she's running a little
bit late uh I have a request to see if
we can finish by 11. uh so so that's
that's a stretch I had been mentally
prepared for noon so we'll we'll see how
this goes are are you are you ready Mr
Ripple okay can somebody just check to
make sure the video is streaming
and uh and with that I'm gonna go out of
order because we are uh we have the
esteem Senator Waters uh here Senate's
very busy these days I'm going to ask
him to come up and introduce SB 239 and
I'm going to ask you if you're familiar
with the way the house amended it on the
floor the other day yeah all right thank
you sir thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee Senator David
Waters District 4 introducing Senate
Bill 239 and I do want to commend the
house Health Human Services committee
and particularly representative Nagel
who's a world you know leading National
expert on these matters for his four
Amendment which I think helped clarify
greatly some definitions and uh and and
procedures
um so I'll very briefly say what the
bill covers as a member of the
governor's commission I saw in the first
part of the bill that we were
establishing harm reduction as one of
the Strategic areas of the governor's
commission so that's why the first
couple of pages of the bill are just
putting harm reduction in there because
if that's our strategic plan includes
that it ought to be in the statute as as
well
this first part relating to the
commission I think also crucially adds
the president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police to the
commission so we'll have more law
enforcement advice on the work that we
are are doing
then if you will turn
onto page
3 of the bill is amended by the house
towards the bottom
section 10 this deals with the
governor's doorways program I want to
commend governor sununu for establishing
a doorways program by executive order
there are 11 of them around the state
they are saving lives every day they are
the point of referral for all kinds of
treatment and services and it seemed to
me since they were established by
executive order because well not by
exactly because of grant funding that
given their success that we ought to
have the program and statute and HHS
agreed so this is the language they
provided it doesn't calm the doorways
but that's basically what it is and a
crucial amendment that Senator Bradley
put in the Senate was to clarify that
this is not calling for State
Appropriations for the doorways program
that they will run on federal existing
Federal grant funding that was the
reason it had an afan over in the Senate
got that clarified and that's why the
fiscal report now is different about
about that the third part of the bill
has to do with our syringe service
programs and paraphernalia
and uh this is an issue that the house
has acted positively on and with a house
bill but this bill was somewhat uh
different for a couple of um uh reasons
uh because of what we heard from
Manchester and other areas about wanting
some coordination and consultation with
the syringe exchange programs
um this is what the chiefs of police
wanted and throughout this section I
just want to note that crucially the
chiefs of police are okay with this
language which they have not been uh in
other treatments of this issue so what
this deals with some of the
preparaphernalia issues essentially by
focusing on the folks who are part of a
registered syringe service program that
they may have these certain items like
fentanyl test strips and uh
um you know water and wound treatment
and other things
for harm reduction without breaking the
law over
possession of paraphernalia so this bill
has that applied to the folks who are
part of a registered syringe service
program and that's an important
distinction but one which um affords
Accords well with law uh enforcement the
next and there's several definitions
then about drug checking equipment on
page five and you know the house bills
similar definitions and so on but that's
important to have in there so that we
know what the eligible activities are
under harm reduction
um then uh the next part of the bill is
at the bottom of page five and this has
to do with education
um representative Nagel being a
physician specialized in this area and
others thought that it was important to
add in the um re-licensing process that
you would have taken done your three
hours a lot of folks don't get this in
medical school and harm reduction is a
growing field so it made a lot of sense
to say that folks would get a little bit
of online training in that then on page
six is primarily what representative
Nagel added in the four Amendment
and as I said what is so helpful here is
it adds important definitions
transparency
clarifications
as to how this approach will be now
utilized uh and um you'll see the kind
of list here's of definition of what
harm reduction actually entails this is
mostly from the samhsa federal website
of these definitions and it Accords
pretty much with the kind of definitions
of harm reduction that we have been
using in the governor's Governor's
commission and it also clarifies
um you know that these are the
approaches for which this funding could
be used
if if provided from Grants and other
things that commission funds and the
opioid task force as well so Mr chairman
I'm sorry to raise through it but that's
these are the main components of it and
you'll see the new physical note says
that because of the amendments to it
there is no
um new appropriation or expenditure in
the Bill thank you uh thank you Senator
are you willing to take questions you
bet yeah okay
um or I I have a few but are there any
questions from the committee
okay
um so
um so I'm going to jump around just a
little bit through the legislation but I
I think I'm not going to miss my points
um now just just to be clear and be
clear for the the public on on page four
on lines 20 through 22 there's a very
specific strikeout here so that uh what
is apparently in current law is that the
use of state general funds shall be
prohibited unless otherwise appropriated
by the general court or if deemed
necessary to control a disease outbreak
so so is so this change as I understand
it would now authorize General funds to
be spent on needle exchange programs is
that is that thank you Mr chairman
um so just a little bit of background
you know I worked for many years with
Senator gray and representative Hannan
on originally setting up the syringe
service programs and uh in the process
of that it was important at that time to
have this Prohibition in there to get
that that bill passed as this program
has matured
um and proven its success one of the
issues has been well sustained
sustainability of funding that right now
it is primarily grant funding and also a
lot of contributions being made by the
hospitals to accept the syringes to put
through their disposal
um stream which can be very expensive
um but there's always a worry that
especially as these expand that we may
need to come forward and ask for State
funds now there's no appropriation the
bill but it says that if if there is a
if there is a request would have to come
to the legislature and get separately
funded by the legislature but having
that out of here I think
um is an is an important recognition of
where the programs are now and the
possibilities that that funding might
now be sought so um it seemed to me that
that that that that prohibition there
was kind of out of date and um a
reflection of the you know earlier
iteration of where we were in these and
now we're in a different place with them
so I hope that answers your question you
did you did I think I think the short
answer is yes this would change
and allow General funds to be spent on
needle exchange programs yes yes
appropriated if appropriate yes are
there I still have more questions is
there any other question uh I don't want
to dominate this uh representatively on
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking the question
um this may just be because this is my
first time sitting in on finance but it
looks to me that the existing language
in that line says that the use so state
general funds shall be prohibited unless
otherwise appropriated by the general
court which appears to already have that
flexibility to me so I'm trying to
understand that disconnect
could you help me understand that
Senator yeah thanks for your question
um
it seems to me you know yes you are
correct in a way but I think it creates
a I mean you are correct but it creates
a higher hurdle here and I think also in
terms of the policy of the state to have
a blanket prohibition unless
specifically
um put forward
um you know it does make it difficult in
terms of when we are going out to buy
for Grants uh and there may be a
possibility of matching funds from some
federal grants so I think that
um this means as a kind of like a
flexibility to it um I think you know
technically you're correct but on the
other hand you know working with these
programs and with the with the folks who
are out there trying to Cobble together
the funding having this heaviness out of
there and you know there there is we do
have some funding sources that are
coming in from the alcohol fund into the
harm reduction programs and is that an
appropriation of the state well some
would say it is
um so there's that I think that this is
why it's a it's helpful to have the
sense the statute would not be silent on
this
do you have a follow-up I I just want to
point out the effect uh that you
observed is that just simply being on
the finance committee raises your IQ 15
points so that that's why you saw that
this time but yeah go ahead if you have
a follow-up um thank you yes my question
would be if those funds for the alcohol
abuse are part of the general fund or if
that's a separately allocated fund
I'm sorry I didn't quite understand it
you spoke to the funds coming from The
Liquor Commission are those General
funds or is that already specifically
appropriated for the use of alcohol and
drug abuse prevention
I'm not exactly sure how that I could
answer that works out maybe you could
the way we look at the budget once
General funds come into another agency
however they come into there they're
called other funds and this is a
dedicated fund so it isn't like we could
use it anywhere else in general funds
it's a dedicated fund specifically the
way the law describes it come out of the
alcohol sales
so then it's a dedicated fund and it
goes into this prevention program so
they would list it as other rather than
General funds thanks okay
so to complete the thought it I I think
along with you that it probably takes on
the nature of being more of a grant than
a an appropriation but but I'm not a
lawyer
um do you have a another follow-up
okay so so Senator Waters um I I had
somebody reach out to me and and say
that they were concerned that um this
would potentially fund safe injection
sites in New Hampshire
can you can you talk about safe and and
for definitions just to get it off the
sides a safe injection site as I
understand it is where you may register
as a as a an addicted person and in
order to help get you off much like we
do methadone but there there are safe
places where you may continue to feed
your drug habit but in a more controlled
safe environment so so I don't think we
have those now the methadone clinics are
something different so so would this
would this open up the door to Safe
injection sites for the the drug that
would otherwise be illegal for
consumption absolutely not and I will
expand on that a little bit as you
recall from our work together on the
harm reduction study committee last
summer we put in our report explicitly
saying that we did not support safe
injection sites and if you look at the
definitions here around water certain
service program can do that in nowhere
is safe injection site allowed under
those programs so I think that the
answer is absolutely not in terms of
whether this would open the door to that
um whether if the state wants to go down
that road that's a whole nother issue
all right thank you and then
um on uh page five at the bottom where
on line 33 the phrase all licenses are
required to register is is that I I read
the word all as potentially being over
broad it's it's mandating uh three hours
of training for all licenses and I I uh
I wonder if that could be or should be
more tailored
thank you for the question I think it is
actually uh Mr chairman because
um it says all licenses and then well
what it what are those licenses those
that are required to to register with
the controlled drug prescription health
and safety program
now those folks you know if you have you
have your prescribing rights for
controlled drugs
that's what your license is and so the
license that allows that are the ones
who would have to complete this because
the folks who don't have that license
aren't aren't prescribing so this is you
know certain
um Physicians nurses
Physicians assistants who have have that
that that prescribing right so that's
why I think it is limited thank you for
that and and do you do you know what the
rationale was for choosing three credit
hours as opposed to one or six or some
other number
um from my understanding and you know I
could ask Dave uh representative Nagel
again but I've done some other work on
this and three hours seems to be the
kind of unit that is used often in these
kind of training programs
um for a lot of for a lot of things that
that seems to be the hours that that
people recognize is getting the training
that gives you what you need so that's
that's why all right thank you are there
uh representative co-falt
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question so uh
just returning to this question of safe
injection sites I think your your
initial question or the initial question
was would this legislation enable
funding of that and your answer was
absolutely not and then towards the end
I I believe I heard you say well whether
the state wants to go down that
particular path that's a different
question so I'm I just want to get
clarity
does the legislation as it is as we have
it today
would it authorize the use of funds for
safe injection sites or not ABS
absolutely not and it would take the
reason I added at the end it would take
separate legislation and very complex
legislation if the state
were to go want to go down that okay
thank you for clarifying as I said our
study committee last summer we said
no great okay thank you for clarifying
that
are are there other questions welcome
representative nordgren good having you
here
do you want to hit your mic or
I'm sorry Mr chair for being late
um they're they're repairing at least
half of Highway 89 so
I'll plan ahead thank you all right just
just so you know we skipped ahead to 239
to as a courtesy to the senator
um are there other questions
thank you Senator do you have any other
concluding remarks based on this
exchange uh just again to say I really
thanked the house for its good work to
improve the bill and uh representative
in particular and
I think we're going to save some lives
thank you thank you sir is there anyone
in the audience who had uh interest in
testifying on Senate bill 239.
so
um
I I think we're going to continue the
discussion before we come back to
discussions on uh on what we might do
with these but so let's pick up Senate
Bill 172 FN
is there anyone here to talk to us about
Senate Bill 172 FN
so um
representative kofault would you would
you please sit at the table and
introduce to 172 for us
you've done this before all you got to
do is just read the title
and and then of course take some really
difficult questions
uh thank you Mr chairman I think so you
you caught me a little bit off guard
um Senate Bill 172
um allows court appointed Guardians to
receive uh temporary assistance to needy
families benefits
um I think the um
yeah the the challenge here was if there
is a parent who is
um really unable to function in that
capacity in a court-appointed guardian
um is is directing the the upbringing of
a child that uh that the state benefits
should be available to them in the same
way that uh that they would if if they
were applied for by a parent
all right thank you
um is there is there if if there are no
ques well there this is where we're
going to have discussions you can take
your uh
but let's talk about this a little bit
uh representative Wallner I I sort of uh
reserved to you my perception that
amongst us you're probably as
knowledgeable on TANF as any of us are
and I'm just curious what you're if you
have any particular thoughts on 172 that
you may care to share with us
no I think it's a really I think it's
really necessary especially when you see
the number of children
who are going in
to our foster care system and there
aren't always appropriate places for
them but there may be court appointed
Guardians
that are not directly related like
grandparent sister those types of
relationships but these are people who
have some connection to the child I
think these are really important
placements and much
um
not always but in a lot of times these
are preferable to a foster family that
isn't does not have a close connection
to the to the child so I think these are
real this is a really important addition
and tana funds are allowed for this
all right uh thank you for that is there
any other discussion on SB 172 anyone in
the crowd care to testify on SB 172
uh not seeing any I'm go ahead uh
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman um just looking at the fiscal
note I see that most of this is going to
be covered by the federal government I'm
just curious if we know if the upgrade
to the Department's Heights eligibility
system at about a million dollars is
covered by federal funds or if that's
State funds
and sorry if I'm trying to take my no no
no no I I really appreciate you taking
this seriously I'm probably going to
kick this over to Mr Ripple or
representative Waller but but TANF is
all federal money uh it uh accumulates a
reserve uh currently the reserve is
fairly significant
um I think it's in the you know 30 40
some million dollars range we did a
couple of uh actions in this last budget
cycle to
obligate around I don't know this is all
memory about 14 million or so and some
some new programs using TANF so the
reserve is actually still quite
significant and it is all federal money
did I say anything wrong there
representative walner sounded right to
me I think the reserve may be higher
than 40 million that might be up around
67 68 million I I I'm just going off a
memory I I would always guess low when
I'm spending other people's money but uh
Mr Ripple do you want to add anything to
that yeah the only thing I would add is
there is a there is a phrase in the
fiscal note that's incorrect as I read
this now it says the TANF program is
fully federally funded there are General
funds used for TANF however I did
confirm with the Department that they
expect this particular program to be
fully federally funded and I think that
applies to the upgrade to the new
heights eligibility system as well and
um the current balance in the TANF
Reserve at least as of the end of
December was about 67 million dollars
uh thank you do you have a follow-up all
right are there any other questions
about
um SB 172 if not I'm going to set it
aside for a moment and uh and move on to
SP
263. I don't I don't see an elected
official to introduce this uh
representative kovalt since we just
broke you in on the Panic introduction
could you
thank you Mr chairman so
um
Senate Bill 263 pertains to extending
the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Health Program
and establishing a commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Healthcare program
um
you're looking for further further
comments no we're just introducing it at
this moment so thank you
um is there anyone in the crowd I see Mr
lippman did you want to an opportunity
to speak specifically to SB 263 or
anyone else in the audience
but we we can start with you Mr Lipman
if you want to say something
a lot has been said in the last couple
of weeks I I don't know if we can talk
about 263 without representative Weber
here but uh but we'll we'll struggle
forward
for the record Henry Littman State
Medicaid director Senator Bradley wasn't
able to be here today asked that I'd be
available to answer any questions that
that you might have
um
as you said it's been discussed fairly
significantly but uh
um if there's anything that any
information that uh
you'd like to uh or any other thoughts
on it that I can help you work through
I'd be happy to do that
uh thank you I don't I don't want to put
you on the spot it didn't sound like you
you've come to say anything specifically
to us and and to your point about
Senator Bradley he did pay me the
courtesy of calling me in advance his
wife is uh he's taken her down to Boston
for some uh routine medical procedures
so uh he couldn't be with us today but
he did call and we did have a
conversation and and one of the things
uh he and I talked about
um is was the idea of the sunset
provision and and I told him I was
disappointed that we couldn't get a
six-year sunset in
and uh and and he he shared he shared a
thought with me that made me think
differently you know you and I have
talked about why six years is a logical
rational number we've got a year to get
through the current budget then we've
got a five-year contract that wants to
be a five-year contract one plus five is
six
he suggested that it would be smart to
be able to write that contract so that
it could also be extended for another
year or two and I I'm not nuts about the
two but I I could see the argument for
seven so so what what are your thoughts
I mean from a from a contracts
standpoint I think um you know from
experience of our last procurement we
did end up needing to extend the
contract to allow the executive Council
to ask more questions and do more public
input
um
I think the extension ended up being
like three or four months
um over what was the original five-year
contract to allow the council to take
the public input they wanted to do and
considering the proposals that came in
and and such so having that flexibility
if that if there is a an agreement among
the parties that to do something
different than what was passed then that
makes sense to me as well
okay uh are there other questions
representatively on thank you Mr
chairman and thank you let Mr lippman
for being here while I'm not an expert
on MCO contracts I did trade options for
a while which are basically Insurance
products
um my curiosity would be that if we had
an option to extend that would only be
when it benefits the state so would that
actually increase the cost of the
contract if we have a free option to
extend this contract for additional
years
I I would agree with you that the only
reason to extend it would be if it was
in benefit to because going out to bid
is for State procurement is I think the
the strategy um to get better uh
experience for the state so again I
think the instance where it got extended
here was because
the interest to have the time to to
Really study a contract it's you know
one of the largest if not the largest
contracts the state enters into
but as a follow-up if we were to
specifically include a one to two year
free option for us to continue the
contract would that increase the the
cost that the mcos would need to provide
to us because we would only extend it
when it was in our interest as opposed
to when renegotiating would be
beneficial
I don't believe that would extend the
cost or increase the cost I think that
um
you know the the big reason for having
an extended contract period or a
five-year period is it does take some
time to recover the Investments that are
required to sort of stand up the whole
program for for them to extend that it
was extended I think it would be
in our favor when we look to negotiate
we're looking at not just what they're
doing in New Hampshire but also in part
what they're doing nationally and or
regionally
um and you know the longer they can
spread the overhead the better we should
be able to do
thank you sort of clarify I think I may
have heard you use the word a free
extension I I just to make sure it's
clear is is that if we exercise the
option to extend it for another one more
year we are also obligated to pay
whatever the costs are at the contracted
rate it's not like we get a free year
correct but I meant by a free option was
the option to extend it for that year
which has value when you have an option
to continue at a currently negotiated
contract as opposed to renegotiating the
contract
um in the future yeah yes ma'am my okay
so thank you we're we're very close to
one another I I I I I would just uh say
that in my experience with Contracting
if it's in the original RFP and the
statement of work that we have the right
to extend for another year then the
bidding process basically Works through
the valuation of that term
so so I I I still think that we would
end up you know paying one way or the
other whether it was an indirect or
direct it would still be in there
in the valuation of the contract
is it possible um if we were to do that
to have the to require a bid for just a
five years straight and then a five-year
with the option to extend because
otherwise that that cost of extension
would be baked into that price that they
Quote us for that five years plus
it may be possible uh I I
I in a previous life I did work a lot
with Federal contracts and so since this
is a I assume this is uh driven by
federal Contracting rules to a very
large extent
um
the uh
we the the the right to exercise the
extension gets put in as an additional
line item and the and as the vendors go
through and and put the pricing
proposals together they incorporate
whatever implication there might be to
that I I it seems to me to be fairly
standard in Government Contracting to to
say the term of this contract is X with
the right to extend it for a year at the
at the government's pleasure or benefit
so so do you do you do you still want
somebody else to come in and testify and
if so what specific question would you
like them to come in to talk about
um I guess specifically I'd like to know
if we could have them delineate that
price of that option to extend so we
understand what that cost of keep of
retaining that option is how many
millions of dollars in order to have the
option to extend it at the end of The
Five-Year process so so I think I
understand you to be saying and I'm just
clarifying that that line item you would
want it to be priced and we wouldn't
know the price of that line item for
many months until they went through the
RFP process and the pricing proposals
came back so so I don't I don't so let's
say your answer your question is is a
viable good question I don't think it
would be practical for us to know the
answer for you know nine months or six
months until we started getting
proposals back do you do you see do you
have any comment on this Mr Lipman yeah
I think it will
it will take some time to see you know
what what how that's going to play out
in terms of how many you know if only
the incumbents bid versus if we have new
entrants that are interested in in the
market
um
but I do think that's something at the
state's option which you know I think
the executive Council kind of has the
ability to if there's the if the term of
the reauthorization is there to be able
to to do what's right at the right time
Weiler
thank you Mr chairman
Mr Lipman if if we go to a PR make this
program permanent
I think it's likely to encourage the
feds to pay less than 90 percent
and what happens should that occur
I think under the current chapter law
that it goes below 90 percent the
program ends that's built into the
current statute regardless of what's put
in this bill
thank you yes so so uh representative
Weiler that that was a specific thing
that uh Senator Bradley wanted me to
understand that this chapter law
enforces the 90 but when I but there's
still there would still be a wind down
it wouldn't be an automatic termination
it would still take time but the other
thing that things that could happen
um that uh could also cause the
legislature some concern would be if
they were to change uh the eligibility
level I think right now is set at like
135 percent of FPL if if the feds change
that policy what implications would it
have for us what if they started to
authorize uh the things under the guise
of medical care that we made have some
disagreements with you know so so I I
still think there's sort of uh a sound
argument for a sunset on the belief that
this could be a really great program six
or seven years from now but we should
not assume
when we don't have to but that that's
that's me talking that
are there are there any other uh
questions for Mr Lipman because I want
to come to you representative kovald I
know that representative Hull has set up
a set of issues that he might want to
would it be better to go through the
that list with Mr lippman here or or or
is it something that's just more with
the legislators talking what what's your
perception I think we can cover it in
the latter category okay all right so so
thank you Mr Lipman and before we get
into the next phase of this is there
anyone else in the audience who have
come specifically to testify about HB
uh I'm gonna thank you Mr Lipman uh Mr
I'm going to recognize Mr Steve Anon did
I get it close that time and not Anon
on him I just got to get the infosis on
the right syllable
yeah all right
um I go by a lot of things yeah uh
welcome thank you good morning Stephen
and president of the New Hampshire
Hospital Association appreciate the
opportunity to uh speak to all of you
um as you know we have said uh time and
again as we have all heard over the last
several months this is an incredibly
important program and a very big
priority for us to reauthorize the New
Hampshire's Medicaid expansion program
it's in our view helping provide the
Right Care at the right time in the
right place for many Granite seders who
were previously uninsured as a result of
the Granite Advantage Healthcare program
we've seen a significant drop in the
amount of uncompensated care that
hospitals are providing to those without
insurance we went from 173 million in
uncompensated care attributed will those
without insurance in 2014 to 2021 to 69
million and that's a direct reflection
of the coverage gains but we're also
seeing a reduction in the number of
uninsured patients who are seeking care
in the emergency room room as inpatients
and as outpatients and that's a that's a
significant benefit because you know we
know that when a patient shows up in the
emergency room in crisis
oftentimes many of those conditions can
be treated
prior to that before it becomes a crisis
and can be managed much more effectively
on an outpatient basis in a clinic in a
primary care office or a specialty
office and that certainly should be our
goal and you know now we have the
ability to get people connected to a
primary care a clinic or or office so
that they can manage those chronic
conditions we also know that it's
providing you know important coverage
for those suffering from mental illness
or misuse and those are incredibly
important benefits for patients so I'm
happy to talk further um but this is not
a hearing I'm not testifying but happy
to answer questions that you might have
further questions
representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman Mr Annan
when someone gets certified as a
hospital in New Hampshire
they're given lots of tax deductions
they don't pay property taxes they may
be the most expensive building in the
complex in the whole town they don't pay
meals and rooms taxes
they don't pay business profits taxes
that's because we know you give
charitable care
so to come and say oh we've given all
this charitable care to my mind it's
somewhat equal to the tax savings that
the state has given you so there's an
expectation that that's the reason why
we give this but with these programs
lately you're giving less and less free
care because with Medicaid and all these
extensions
you're giving you're getting him
somewhat reimbursed for things you
weren't reimbursed with before so
you know I don't I I wonder if we're
really getting our values worth by
giving you all these tax deductions
thank you uh Mr chairman I would say
um hospitals are providing an incredible
value to their Community
um the tax-exempt uh Provisions
um are allowed for non-profit entities
like hospitals that provide a broad
Community uh benefit and some of that is
certainly uh folks who don't have
insurance so providing care to those
that don't have insurance it's also
providing services without reimbursement
in the Community Education screenings
other kinds of things
um and uh you know hospitals continue to
provide
significant amounts of uncompensated
care but they're also doing a whole host
of things as we think about the hospital
outside of the Four Walls of the
hospital as they reach out into the
community to help their communities and
their patients live healthier lives as
we talk about health care we often think
about what happens inside the doctor's
office or what happens inside the
hospital but so much of what determines
one's health is actually outside of the
Health Care system so it's housing it's
food it's Transportation it's a whole
host of things that hospitals are
working very hard in their communities
with other partners to address so I I
absolutely uh you know certainly
appreciate the the tax exam Provisions
that allow hospitals to work in their
communities but absolutely believe it's
an incredible investment that the state
and the federal government are making
and we appreciate that and we believe
it's a it's a much more than a fair uh
trade-off
follow up do you have one no uh
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Anand for being here my
question is actually on the calculation
of uncompensated care I was curious if
that's the build rate the Medicaid
reimbursement rate or how that
uncompensated care is calculated so
uncompensated care is always build on
the charged rate
um that um so that we're all talking the
same language
um and um
so hopefully that answers your question
um it does and as a follow-up is it
possible to um I guess it'd probably be
proprietary to know the difference
between the charged rate for all of your
regular care and what you're actually
paid not just on Medicaid services but
by by insurers unfortunately that's not
a number that I have access to those are
proprietary rates that are negotiated
between providers as and and carriers
obviously the Medicaid rate is known
um uh it's not negotiated nor is the
Medicare rate Medicare pays somewhere in
the neighborhood of about 80 cents on
the dollar and Medicaid substantially
less
um uh for for hospital care
would it be possible to find out what
that level of uncompensated care was
using the Medicaid build rate as opposed
to that full charged rate
I'll have to go back and and see what we
can parse out thank you
any other questions uh representative
Stringham well I I just kind of make a
comment on that discussion hospitals are
required to submit uh Revenue Center
specific cost reports by hospital and
you can calculate an overall ratio of
cost to charges is public information
so based on standard build rates and um
uh
you know be happy to look them up for
you if you'd like
um any other questions for our guest uh
thank you thank you
uh representative is are there is there
anyone else in the
audience that came in today hoping to
speak to the committee
uh with that then representative
co-fault would you
um what we're about to do here is a
representative hole and others have
spent a lot of time taking a look at
this bill and at a courtesy and an
interest in learning something uh he
couldn't be here today so he's asked
representative co-fault to represent a
set of bullet items that have a
significant impact on the bill
my request is going to be that we focus
on the items that may have a more of a
financial than a policy of implication
but I I think I think we should hear
them so with that representative
colfault would you make us smarter
um
thank you Mr chairman I so
representative Hull sent me a number of
of points and I think
um one or two of them probably I I will
omit because I think they really are
squarely in the in the realm of policy
uh not necessarily with financial
implications but
um
I think a number of the issues that have
been a number of the concerns that have
been raised
um are you know they they range from the
the lack of a functional work
requirement as it is and then by
extension a desire to uh to add to
statute that DHHS will apply for a a
waiver
um for the work requirement
um there are other
um concerns that representative Hull
raised regarding the need for some kind
of a copay
and that that coverage should should
ramp and not sort of a step function to
to get off of of uh the coverage
um that there needs to be a cap on the
program length for someone who's on it
that this should be a step up or a hand
up not a handout that becomes uh
permanent
to clarify that's just the individual
client level not at the program level
correct
um
that there needs to be a severability
clause uh that there are no Good
callback provisions and the federal
government requires that
um
there representative Hull also pointed
to the to issues about
um
no sterilization quote in quotes
sterilization procedures for those under
37 I think that may be more of a policy
issue
um some form of a drug testing I'm not
sure if I if I covered that one or not I
guess and then I will add my own uh my
own two cents that I think sort of
um
reflect some of these but it's sort of a
bigger bigger concern about scope creep
and the need for a sunset Clause because
I can tell you in Health and Human
Services we routinely see bills come
through that that add one thing or
another to
to Medicaid benefits currently I think
we have a bill retained that would add a
vision screening program for children
and without going into the the merits of
that program or lack thereof I'll simply
say it's one more thing that that
adds to the to the cost of what is
currently a very very expensive program
to begin with so
circling back to the need for a sunset
clause and
um
really feeling that if we don't have
that kind of periodic review the size
the scope the complexity of this program
really merits that you know
close attention and periodic review and
reauthorization by the legislature so I
think that's that's probably the single
you know biggest uh biggest sticking
point here
so I want to go first on this on the
sterilization up the ban on
sterilization up to the age of 37. I
want to make sure that this is in the
proper box uh would would the the
definition of sterilization in uh
include uh gender reassignment surgeries
where a person lost their ability to
reproduce is that would that be in
effect a sterilization procedure
I'm not clear on that I'll let
representative Leon answer that
um thank you the clear thank you Mr
chairman the Clear and Present issue um
that was raised by that is that there
are women with uterine cancer cervical
cancer who are being denied coverage for
a hysterectomy because they have not
reached the age of 37 or had children so
rather than removing a cancerous body
part they're being told to hold on wait
till you're 37 and hopefully your
disease hasn't progressed and Nationwide
women have died from that waiting okay
so I I clearly misunderstood the bullet
point I thought it was a ban saying you
could not get a sterilization procedure
until the age of 37 what I hear you
saying is that we we want the the
medical policy to be
that under the age of 37 this if a woman
needs a hysterectomy or whatever that
that's a viable procedure that should be
considered and and paid for if elected
yes the intention is so that when the
MCO contracts are negotiated they're
prohibited from rationing care for
hysterectomies especially
we're particularly concerned around
those cancer needs but to make sure that
care isn't restricted for adult women
simply because they haven't reached a
certain age or had a certain number of
children
it can be endometriosis it can be cancer
there can be things where that is the
clearing indicated need but currently
our State Medicaid Program has denied
women that care okay so and you have
like you know documented cases where
that care has been denied this is a real
thing and not as a story we've had
constituents reach out for that specific
on the granite Advantage program thank
you uh representative I'm questioning
how this it relates to the fiscal impact
I thought we weren't going to discuss
policy
we that's a fair question uh I I would
say in this specific instance uh there's
a financial implication to authorizing
care but that's lower than a and a
current cutoff date that if in theory if
you're doing procedures on a 36 year old
that you were going to postpone you're
spending that money now instead of in
the future and then there's the ongoing
health care cost issue of in general the
earlier you intervene in a in a
patient's care the better the overall
outcome and the reduction of cost
usually goes along with that that that
that's sort of how I think it's covered
today in fiscal we're going to get into
that if we start discussing age for
mammograms age for colonoscopies age for
a whole slew of things that does not
fall into the purview of this committee
uh potentially but I don't see the real
threat of that because we were at a
specific list of items that
representative kovalt received from
representative hole as being sort of
more critical and that he's further
filtered it to those that he thinks has
a more direct Financial impact and and
so far what I've heard is that there
there can be a financial impact of each
of those bullet statements do you want
to just read the bullet statements again
can you just summarize the bullet
statements and and and if we could get a
copy to uh representative Stringham I'd
like to make sure that the notes are up
to date sure happy to do that so
um there's no current
or functional work requirement or
unemployment training requirement
coverage needs to be a ramp not a step
function to get off the program there
needs to be a cap on the program length
for somebody who's on it there needs to
be a severability clause there needs to
be a sunset Clause uh there are new no
good clawback provisions and those
representative Hull's understanding is
that the federal government requires
that
um
I mentioned the the sterilization issue
we were just talking about some form of
copay
ought to be required some form of drug
testing ought to be required and uh
there should be a provision that DHHS
must apply for a waiver on the work
requirement
do you have a follow-up
[Music]
representative or walner
says I listened to the list
they sounded sort of familiar to me and
I think that many of these things came
forth last week as amendments
and the house voted to reject them
so I don't see how bringing them up at
this point
is really necessary and particularly
that most of the things on the list were
not related to finances
uh thank you any other comments
representative uh Leon
um thank you Mr chairman
um that that may have been the case
however debate was limited and in the
Parliamentary inquiries on the drug
testing it was clear that the amendment
was not actually read through because
it's specifically Exempted people with
substance use disorder treatment and
those who have been prescribed the drugs
by their physician and so by the lack of
debate on the floor I think that these
do impact the fiscal impact fiscal and
they were not thoroughly considered by
the house as amendments because debate
was limited
representative norgren
thank you Mr chair I would just make a
comment that the list of things we're
talking about all the issues seem to be
90 percent women's issues
so I have a concern that we've really
gotten into the whole policy
discussion rather than financial
thank you
I I hear you I I don't I don't make the
distinction we're talking about money
and in general I'm very Pro making sure
women have
Superior health care so I don't I don't
I don't understand that concern but I do
hear you uh what what I'd like to do at
this point is recess
um
I I think I think we could recess for
um about
let's say 1105 and representative walner
I am trying to wrap this up so so let's
recess to uh 1105 and then come back and
and at that point I'd like to hear what
the committee wants to do with these
three bills
all right recess
foreign
all right it's uh it's 1108 I had asked
for us to go into recess to 1105 so
we're just coming back a little late
uh representative tolerski is there she
is I think we're now all present
um having heard and had an opportunity
to discuss these three bills
um I I would like us to determine what
our recommendation is to the full
finance committee uh or is there a
motion on SB 239
yes Mr chair I'd like to make a motion
on Senate Bill 239
my motion is to retain
is there a second
it's been uh motioned and seconded is
there discussion
represent Leon thank you Mr chairman
um and I I want to thank Senator waters
for bringing something to my attention I
had been very very convinced that we
needed to have house bill 287 on the
drug checking so that this program would
be enabled and I had missed the language
notwithstanding any other law to the
contrary that is on page four line 26. I
appreciate that in terms of the drug
checking but I'm very curious what other
laws may not need to be followed in this
and I think that this requires a
significant amount of follow-up
so in this in what you're imagining for
follow-up
um do you do you if if Finance keeps it
it still feels to me appropriate to do
more of a joint effort between
hhsea and division three what what are
your thoughts on that I think that that
makes a lot of sense this is something
where we could look at this and look
within the syringe service programs to
figure out what other laws they may need
to be shielded from and specifically
call out whether they're notwithstanding
any other laws regarding Controlled
Substances to the contrary or if there's
any others that are also necessary for
their implementation I don't know if
there's anything about capacity issues I
don't know if there's any building code
issues I don't know what else is
necessary and I think that before we
pass something with the language not
with sending any other law to the
contrary that needs to be done and I
apologize for not catching this in HHS I
I truly believed that we needed House
Bill 287 to change drug checking
equipment in order to be able to to test
drugs
represent walner yes I just would like
to know if I could ask representative
Mooney
if she had other pieces of information
she needed before she moved forward on
this bill what would what would she be
looking for in a for retaining this bill
what did you have in mind
uh thank you for the question no no
further information needed just based on
discussions and information related to
harm reduction I think comments that
were made by representative Leon
the best motion here would be to retain
do you have a follow-up no thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman so my concern
about this bill
um has to do with the definition of harm
reduction and
um the the implications in terms of sort
of overall scope and uh and cost
the
uh the the definition of harm reduction
we heard from a number of experts in HHS
and and it was interesting that the the
definition of harm reduction and whether
it overlaps with treatment or doesn't
overlap with treatment and
whether specific things might be
included or not it was all over the map
and
um as the co-sponsor of the floor
Amendment with Dr Nagel
um you know we we have made an attempt
to further refine that definition so
that it was not
so broad that you could
potentially buy someone a house to
improve their social and mental
well-being
um
while I'm pleased that we made progress
on that I've subsequently been hearing I
also have have had someone raise the the
concern about safe injection sites and
that being labeled specifically as harm
reduction in other states so my concern
is that in order to
spend this money wisely
we need to do some more work on defining
exactly what we mean by harm reduction
if I may I'll tell a little bit of a
personal story I used to work for
Phillips Medical Systems I would spend a
lot of time in the Netherlands I would
spend weekends in Amsterdam and so I it
feels to me the harm reduction program
and concepts are almost 10 years behind
what was going on in the Netherlands
they they tried a bunch of
needle
needle replacement strategies and safe
injection sites and the like and they
struggled with it and their drug problem
actually
exploded and they rescinded all of those
statutes and went back to more law
enforcement mechanism so so I I I I
think I can support retain because I I
don't know the extent to which we've
looked at this in terms of international
Lessons Learned for example the
Netherlands specifically would be
illustrative in my view
uh are there do you representative
tolersky thank you I'm I will not
support the retained motion
um I feel that it was quite clear
um
from the senator that this bill would
not allow for um a safe syringe
um location whatever the terminology is
um and I feel that we need to move
forward with
um what the house passed in terms of the
definitions
um you know this is a much needed step
forward to bring
um to assist in our Battle of
um drug abuse here in the state and I
think that this will save lives and I am
extremely disappointed that at this
point
um there's you know lines that were
missed in in the first committee but
perhaps since it was amended in a
committee of conference we could come to
some kind of agreement
to be able to get to that final product
but at this point I won't be supporting
retained
thank you are there other comments
questions
representative co-fault
uh thank you just just to clarify my
previous comment I I am also Satisfied
by Senator Waters statement that you
know you know he has said that
harm reduction in this case does not
include safe injection sites my bigger
concern at this point is are there other
things that we're not aware of that
might be objectionable that could be
included in that definition so that's
why I believe it needs it need that
definition needs further work and
refinement
in in my my major Financial view on this
if I just had could pick one would be on
page four where we strike out lines 20
21 and 22. uh I I think the prohibition
of using state general funds uh to pay
for needle exchanges is still the right
financial and social policy so I would
like us to take a look at that we we
have a motion uh that's been heard and
seconded to retain are you ready for you
have a comment or are you ready for the
vote I have a question go ahead um what
what what is our time schedule meaning
when do we have when does this when does
it have to come out of second committee
so uh that that's a good question but if
the whole committee takes adopts our
recommendation to retain the answer
becomes different it becomes that we
should have our work done and our
recommendation done by January
and if it's not retained
uh then another motion would be
considered
and and let's just hypothetically say
that
um
that the bill is not retained by full
committee when does it have to report to
the house floor that that's a good
question my vice chair who is on top of
all of these things is sticking her
finger on June is that June 8.
June is the last day to act on Senate
bills so that means we have a little bit
of time to get it to finance but to
representative Weiler would would have
to have this done by January 8th
wouldn't it have to come out of our
committee June 8th pardon me Mr chairman
wouldn't it need to come out of our wait
wait wait wait wait too many
conversations did you let since I just
invoked your name as the chair do you
have something to say on that sir
June 8th is a calendar it should be
ready for the calendar ah so two days
before that
all right so representative I was just
going to say I misunderstood the dates I
believed that June 8th was the day for
it to come out of the house and so it
would need to be in the calendar the
week prior for our session so June 1st I
believe would be the last day that our
committee could act to hit the calendar
that night
which is next Thursday
so so because I'm having trouble
processing verbal information right now
what's the bottom line when does the
finance committee have to make a vote I
believe it's June 1st June 1st we have
we're ready to exec the bills that have
come before divisions all right thank
you June 1 does that answer your
question
yes thank you Mr chair
okay are we ready for a vote are you
ready to record a vote
would the clerk call of a roll uh motion
to retain 239.
yeah the most the motion is to retain on
House Bill 239
um
uh representative Mooney yes
representative Leon yes representative
kofalk yes
uh representative Wallner
no
Representative nordgren no
representative tolersky
no
uh representative Stringham votes no
represented Weiler or chairman yes yes
and representative Edwards yes
vote is five to four to make a
recommendation of retain
uh thank you Mr clerk
um moving on I would entertain a motion
on Senate Bill
263. representative Mooney Mr chairman I
like to make a motion on Senate Bill 263
the motion is to retain
do I hear a second
it's been motioned and seconded Is there
further discussion representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman I would first like
to just
bring up that we are not discussing
renewal of Medicaid that is not in
question in fact there's no question at
all that Medicaid will be renewed
we have thousands in our state that rely
and depend on it
the question at hand is the time frame
as to whether or not it should be
renewed after a certain period of time
after an extension
or should it be approved right now
forever
to me a contract this big a program so
large no matter what the content should
be renewed after a period of time
the huge disagreement about that it
seems many amendments many questions
so I would ask that this bill be
retained so that those things can be
squared away and I would also bring up
that we have in House Bill 2
an extension for two years a good
starting point in terms of negotiations
with the Senate
so this is on the table already
but for this bill being as large as it
is going on Infinity and Beyond
First Time Finance has seen this being
extended so far
I think the right thing to do is to
retain and I would ask my colleagues to
support that motion thank you Mr chair
further discussion
representative Stringham yeah I will
vote against the motion to retain I
think you know all the issues uh that
were brought up uh could be handled
um uh by separate bill and stepping away
from the sunset they're all definitely
settled policy uh at this point so you I
know you were mostly talking about in
Premiere perspective about uh whether uh
Medicaid would be a permanent extension
uh
you know one point concerns were
expressed to me about the federal
government changing
uh the financial numbers uh to pay less
than 90 percent we already know that's
already built into the law so we have
that protection
and we'll we'll always have opportunity
to bring bring new new issues regarding
the Medicaid Program it's proven its
worth and it's passed unanimously in the
Senate uh and it it passed with an
overwhelming majority in the house
already I don't see any reason to retain
this bill
thank you um representative Leon you
have another
um yes thank you Mr chairman
um I think that the the policy of a
sunset is absolutely critical we've had
vigorous debate in this body about some
programs increasing their participation
rate from 300 percent of the federal
poverty level to 350 percent without a
sunset this body doesn't have any say in
what Washington DC sets as the coverage
limit and that has huge fiscal
implications but beyond that I think
that there's a huge value to retaining
this bill right now Medicaid expansion
and the work requirements are in play in
Washington DC and their in their debt
ceiling debate if we have already gone
home for the summer and we haven't done
anything and there's more major changes
to the program we have no opportunity if
we have not retained this bill so by
retaining this bill it would give this
committee an opportunity to address any
changing scenarios coming out of
Washington DC which I think is highly
beneficial
other comments other discussion
um
not seeing any
uh I think uh I think we're ready for a
vote on
are you ready Mr Clark
thank you
uh representative Mooney yes
it's on the motion to retain uh
representative Leon yes
representative kofelt yes
representative walner
no
Representative nordgren no
Representative tolerski no
representative Stringham votes no
representative Weiler
chairman Edwards yes
uh the vote uh the vote uh is five to
four to recommend to the full committee
to retain the Bill thank you
um that leaves our final bill for
consideration today Senate Bill 172 is
there a motion
a representative Mooney you're
recognized thank you Mr chair I would
move on Senate Bill 172 ought to pass is
there a second second seconded by
representative Wallner
um so it's been moved and seconded
um is there a discussion
not seeing any just oh is there a
discussion over here
do you want go go ahead representative
Mooney you're recognize for discussion
thank you Mr chairman yes I would ask
everyone to support Senate Bill 172. uh
this let's remember came out of children
family law 14 and nothing on a Voice
vote on the floor very important and uh
certainly a gap that needs to be filled
in our TANF laws so I would encourage
everyone to vote ought to pass thank you
all right any further conversation do
you have any representative Stringham no
if you're ready for the vote would you
please repeat that ought to pass on
House Bill 172 representative Mooney yes
representative Leon yes representative
yes representative Wallner
yes
representative nordgren yes
representative tolerski yes
uh represent representative Stringham
votes yes uh representative Weiler yes
chairman Edwards yes
a vote being nine to nothing the
recommendation to the full committee is
ought to pass all right uh thank you Mr
clerk
um I I need somebody who remembers this
stuff better than me uh to tell me what
we need to do about uh writing blurbs is
that is that due to at the end of today
or or when when must those be done we
don't usually write give them ready for
the um
June 1st
um
full committee meeting
all right so nothing required today or
tomorrow all right
okay well so uh with that of the
division three has come together we've
heard our business
um and uh I think we can close this work
session uh at whatever time it is 11 27.
foreign